dominique fortier passe à l'histoire en
devenant la première écrivaine
canadienne à recevoir le prix renaudot
catégorie essai pour son livre les
villes de papier je suis encore un peu
incrédule le progrès c'est comme si
j'arrivais pas à y croire tout à fait
mais je suis vraiment très très heureuse
parce que c'est un arrêt important qui
c'est un jalon important dans la vie
d'un livre c'est sûr que ça donne une
visibilité extraordinaire tu es en
france n'y est vraiment pas beaucoup de
gens qui me connaissent mais tous les
français connaissent le prix renaudot
les villes de papier est un livre sur la
poétesse américaine du 19e siècle
emily dickinson isolé et recluse emily
dickinson n'a presque pas publié de son
vivant
les villes de papier a été écoulé à 11
mille exemplaires au québec
son éditeur a lancé une réimpression
j'ai appris avec dominique à ne pas être
surpris de ce qui lui arrive déjà avec
le gouverneur général pour au péril de
la mer quelques années c'est une très
belle surprise
traductrice d'une quarantaine d'ouvragés
et aux tristes de sept livres
dominique fortier 48 ans a une longue
feuille de route
antonine maillet se réjouit de son
succès j'ai beaucoup aimé ce et livia
parce qu'il ya une poésie réel
elle parle d'un poète mais elle devient
le poète elle même et c'est ça qui
émerveille dany laferrière prix médicis
2009 a aussi tenu à saluer dominique
fortier c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour dominique fortier et qui viennent
une autre est fracassante dans la
littérature française
en france ce prix renaudot est
l'équivalent d'un oscar au cinéma un
signe que la littérature québécoise se
porte bien que dominique est pu mettre
la main sur ce prix là c'est vraiment un
go pour que les autres femmes aussi lé
vent dans les voiles
c'est aussi ça la bonne nouvelle dans
cette histoire traduit en anglais en
italien et bientôt en espagnol et en
suédois avec le renaudot le livre livres
de papier volera encore plus loin est-ce
qu'il va rester je pense c'est cette
nouvelle fenêtre pour mon livre sept
nouveaux sauf qui lui est donné si ça
c'est précieux
ici louis fait depuis mai radio canada